- I already know
what I have to do.
I know you ethos of
document, not create.
So I know what I
have to do but just--
- [Gary] You're not there yet.
- I'm not there yet.
- You know, you're here
because you know I'm right.
- Yeah, of course, yeah.
- I can say like maybe
tonight's the night where
I'm like just do it.
Fuck them.
- Yeah.
- But the truth is even if
you feel the high from me if
I miraculously came up with an
amazing thing to say to you
right now, the truth is
next Thursday happens and
I'm not here.
- That's true.
- So what I would say is the
fact that you even know I'm
right, so you understand, the
reason people leave negative
comments on me or they don't
like me some people here didn't
like didn't like me at first is
because I'm not letting you get
away with your bullshit.
I'm getting to the point of it
and the people I don't like me
are the ones that want to
pay other people or want other
people that show them
Lamborghinis or watches.
They want to trick them.
They want to trick
them into feeling good.
There's only work.
There's only not
caring about every else.
You know what to do.
You grew up in a
way, environment,
parents, DNA that
hasn't let you get there yet.
But the fact that you're even
here and you basically said what
you have to do to me.
I didn't say anything.
- Yeah, I know, yeah.
- It's just a matter time now.
What you need to do
is keep pressure on it.
The reason I never change my
tune is the reason I'm getting
so many people to do
things is 'cause I don't waiver.
It's constant offense.
I'm gonna pound you
every day, every day,
multiple times a day
with the same fucking thing.
It never changes.
It's the same thing.
Luckily for me there's new
platforms so it feels like I'm
saying something new
'cause shit's changing
but it's the same thing.
It's the same thing and you'll
just eventually get there.
What you need to do is you
need to keep paying attention to
people like me or
others that sound like me
so that it becomes your norm.
It becomes your oxygen.
There is no other voices and
eventually just like when you
jumped off of a
diving board to a pool,
just like when you kiss
somebody for the first time,
just like anything else you ever
did in life eventually you get
there and you do it
and you never look back.
- Okay.
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- So the key is to suffocate
yourself into pressuring
yourself to have
no other options.
- Okay.
- The reason I'm worth listening
to it's 'cause I'll do that for
you and then you
don't need anymore.
- Okay, thank you.
- Yeah.
I don't need to
sell you anything.
I don't want you to stay around.
- I just want
one favor if you can.
- Yeah?
- Just scream in my
face just fucking do it.
- I don't even want to do that.
I'll tell you why.
I don't want to 'cause
I don't feel it's right.
You know why?
- Why not?
- 'Cause it's tactical.
- But it's just a
mental thing, I think.
- No. You want
me to fix the sink.
I want you to fix your well.
- [Man] Damn.
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- You just want me to
fix your sink right now.
- Yeah.
- I don't want to do that.
You already know the answer.
My screaming in your
face will be a fun moment.
- Yeah.
- It'll be cool
to think back to.
It's not what
you need right now.
What you need is constant
pressure on any voice that's
penetrating you that isn't
allowing you to make that jump.
Whether that's your mom or older
brother or your aunt or your
best friend or your girlfriend
or your boyfriend I don't know
who the fuck that is but
you need to eliminate it.
- Okay.
- You don't have to cut
them out like that other like,
when I say cut friendship out
I mean I have friends that
I don't listen to a
fucking word they say.
They're my friends but I don't
take their words as my gospel.
You know what
to do, I heard you.
That's why I'm not
gonna give it to you.
I heard you.
- Yeah.
- I know you're ready.
- You know what you are?
Just a matter of time.
("Deep Cut" by Don Annix)